bien domaine où les coupes et les coupes
seront font se défont ça passe à gauche
à droite devant derrière la basse et la
téléréalité vidéo gag en télé réalité on
dirait que cupidon plane au dessus des
émissions huawei c'est vrai que c'est
beau bref souvent vous vous demandez
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je veux savoir
comment fonctionne l'amour dans la télé
réalité vous saurez où ou premièrement
travail et une approche convaincante et
une drague subtil prochaine
j'ai l'habitude de travailler la viande
de qualité comme ça je connais pas
désolé messieurs mais en face de vous
c'est pas un tournedos 1 c'est une femme
petite activité romantique à présent
pour faire plaisir c'est genre faire une
vraie surprise
je crie vu quelque chose oui faire de
l'équitation jim hawkes et sa 6è 7è
manche est très heureux on va faire du
cheval qui soit le cheval alors on
n'oubliera pas son cahier de vacances de
cp mais en attendant après un moment
partagé
très vite c'est la galoche fait que la
fête la musique danse et fait un petit
vise haut
mais comme en télé réalité les couples
ça dure pas longtemps assez rapidement
[Musique]
c'est vraiment
en gros ce qu'elle voulait dire la dame
c'est que y'a trop choses qui se sont
passées trop de christ j'en ai marre en
voilà donc dans ces cas là le mieux
c'est que après c'est sur faut prévoir
un petit temps de digestion pas avoir la
force de continuer
le temps de pleurer en slip dans sa
chambre quoi
hier
mais ça ne se termine pas toujours en
cacahuète non il ya aussi de jolis happy
ending qui rendent tout le monde heureux
enfin sauf peut-être les orthophonistes
policiers
volley méprisé mon coeur alala l'amour
est ce que c'est bon allez d'ailleurs on
se demande si c'est vraiment vrai
regardez ça fait en télé réalité quand
les célibataires parle d'amour ils
disent toujours c'est pas c'est pas moi
c'est un motif alors qu à la première
personne un chien qui veulent et pécho
ils répondent
bah ouais bref vous voulez un résumé des
histoires d'amour en télé réalité on me
jalouse m alors c'est parti pour du love
c'est cette et des réflexions cuqueron
peau de voir des gens qui s'aiment autun
avec autant d'émotion on y va avec
plaisir la télé réalité est souvent le
théâtre des déclarations les plus pour
ave comme la solitude des fiançailles
moisi de nadège et des demandeurs me
coiffer ses demandes ils se sont pris
dans les bras c'était très émouvant à un
détail près à ton avis bayonne où laval
où colas demander en fiançailles sans
bike c'est quand même ce lot on est
d'accord mais celle les empêche
visiblement pas de faire des mariages
avec des filtres snap dégueu sur la tête
par ailleurs
je te prends toi a dit chuck comme mon
épouse et des wheat ou nuls acceptes tu
cette alliance comme signe de mon amour
oui je veux bref en télé réalité comme
dans la vie on se marie et oui parce
qu'il ya aussi des situations de grave
crise à devoir gérer au mon dieu tu la
compagnie de la compagnie de la coop
alix c'est la compagnie vite il faut
aller faire des courses en slip à la
supérette en string
[Musique]
vitryat va des mélanges
ce shampooing
et merde n'y a pas d'acheteur shampoing
[Musique]
dur il faut savoir surmonter ces moments
difficiles
parce que c'est vrai que dans ces
émissions les histoires commencent
souvent comme ça sauf que très vite
ah oui il y a qu'à prendre ricardo et
nude à jeumont tout de suite
une blague ou pas là tu te pizol le
pilote a pas toujours aucun problème je
bluff ou encore thibaut et shana
j'arrive plus j'arrive le juge ejaz
chevelu à venir vers toi j'avais pleuré
mais heureusement l'amour finit toujours
par triompher
[Musique]
c'est une blague ou pas
allez thibault illumine le monde par la
puissance de sa rhétorique boitant
j'sais pas comment fait jamais fait bon
vous l'aurez compris comme tout ça c'est
la musique autant ce qui t'est avec la
plus belle image d'amours illégitimes
pressé de vous devez partir de là c'est
un enchaînement de rien est-ce qu'on
peut dire que m'avait piqué mon texte
avant et donc c'est de ma faute
non mais c'est pas de votre faute on va
magnéto jeunes enfants ballon on va
revenir quand même vu que tu as tant sur
la télé réalité qui insiste sur les
couples de l'airé taylor c'est du fait
du passé qu'eric aux couples qui durent
nabila et thomas ya le premier couple du
loft que j'ai présentée alors il ya ta
tiana aussi et son chéri ouais ouais
ah c'est toujours grave à bah oui bien
sûr vous m'en direz tant
je regrette en fait 3 700 candidats
la différence va jamais assez que dans
le temps il ya 10 ans 15 ans début la
série t il en faisant il ya dix ans un
premier obstacle
yakari ça faisait sept ans 10e dans la
salle il voit les chiffres ça fait 2-1
une pénalité par an bon du coup c'était
fini c'était une vraie histoire ça même
pas 0 faire d'autre maintenant il les
enchaîne il termine t ry t il enchaîne
la suivante trois semaines après et
j'avais comme la vérité ne marche en
tout cas ils sont embauchés que si l
histoire de coeur de couple fans de
cours de futurs couples s'y sont déjà en
couple au début de l'aventuré
ça marche pas il lui faut qu'ils ne sont
pas pris donc même quand ils s'en
foutent ils font croire à chanter
ensemble parce qu'il est parti se
rassure à dos les jeunes étaient
convaincus et apporte un peu de fond
dans l'émission l'intérêt du fonds c'est
qu'on comprenne ce qu'il a apporté en
français ça sera bien mais en vrai les
couples et des télévisions
en vrai ça existe depuis une vraie
quinzaine d'années en prison vous été le
premier en 2001 ont créé les couples à
bec l'île de la tentation quelques
années après on les mettait à la
[Musique]
dédaigner mais j'ai il faut mettre
daniel dans une télé réalité il ne
l'attend porté essentiellement à l'amour
est aveugle
[Rires]
c'est bon
oui mais qui font rire
on va faire une bâche de règles mais
j'adore wii ou la villa des coeurs
brisés
si vous regardez chez kia une candidate
qui est là daniel moreau qui est prête à
faire la moue gtoi avec dix prétendants
mais amour est dans le pré et tout ça
dans un lit intéressant dans la télé
réalité c'est qu'il se mettait parfois
vraiment en couple mais comme ils ont
besoin effectivement de faire planer
mission pour vivre parfois après se
payer de la villa d'arcore brisé et fall
est célibataire ou faire les princes et
les mots fait c'est ma terre dont qu'ils
arrivaient et moi me dit on va se
séparer pour faire une émission faut
être célibataire s'est foutu de ma
gueule pour la différence c'est que nous
on l'a compris il va écouter ses
charismes alors vous jean michel vous
avez fait la télé à l'idée aux douze
jours on se connaît vous avez raison des
anges les anges
alors mesdames personne ne voulait y
aller j'étais le seul à vouloir jamais
ça faisait beaucoup d'avions pour eux
restent à jouer mais c'est l'expérience
au moins je sais de quoi je parle quand
je parle un peu de vous deux de mes
souvenirs c'était pas du jet ce qui est
arrivé c'est bon mais c'est pas vous qui
conduisait à regarder non pas du tout on
est très content de t'avoir
on va faire une bonne journée sap rêvé
d'être répond c'est toujours moi non
mais je n'ai que j'ai l'air con j'avais
une super robot je vais bien je te
personnes sont gentils pour l'instant et
soit elles sont jolies son nom s'étale
sur près d amiens surprise aujourd'hui
la première
[Applaudissements]
c'est très fatigant que vous êtes filmés
à longueur de 2 2 tandis merci m
c'est même marrant que tu fasses devant
un rideau tu donnes un coup de rideau
temps en temps quelqu'un qui fait à
éduquer les poteaux il ya des gens qui
prennent des notes parce qu'il note
louis pour débriefer déjà quand de
l'avant savoir les moments qui sont
intéressants les moments où on peut déjà
[ __ ] à la poubelle
tu pourras entre un étoilé quelqu'un
vous film quand on rentrait d'un tel
vous sortez ya une caméra qui vous
attend sur la sortie des toilettes
donc on peut rien faire là bas ça c'est
celui-là mouche le travail au final si
vous